ahead of its start we got a
behind-the-scenes look at apex legends
season 6 boosted
that includes details that haven't been
fully explained in the trailers that
have been released thus far
with season six about to begin let's go
over everything we know
all right so rampart as we suspected
rampart is a defender she specializes in
directional defense deterring enemy
squads from certain locations while
fortifying her squad's position
her tactical ability is similar to
titanfall 2's a-wall called amped cover
rampart can place five on the
battlefield at a time when first place
they're vulnerable and easily destroyed
but after a few seconds they reinforce
themselves and erect a shield
the shield is one way so make sure
you're not placing it backwards
rampart's ultimate ability is in-place
minigun when used rampart puts down
sheila which she her teammates can use
to lay down suppressive fire the gun
becomes more accurate the longer you
hold the trigger
discouraging you from firing in small
bursts the new legend is pretty unique
in that she's the first to have an
ability that makes her specifically
better with a type of weapon in
comparison to her teammates
rampart's passive ability modded loader
allows her to reload lmgs faster and
gives her 50
more ammo per clip with lmgs in terms of
the lstar which
doesn't have a clip rampart is able to
fire the gun for a longer period of time
before it overheats
speaking of lmgs season 6 sees the
devotion rotated back into the normal
loop pool
and it's bringing back both the
turbocharger hop up and extended energy
mags
in its place the r99 is being rotated
into care packages
don't be sad about the r99 leaving the
general loot pool we have a new smg to
take its place the volt is coming to
apex legends in season six
offering a similar fire rate to the
alternator as an energy ammo gun the
volt's bullets don't lose speed in
mid-air and travel a lot further
giving you a mid to long range smg
option it takes a barrel stabilizer
extended energy mag
smg scope and standard stock attachments
just like season 4's heavy metal and
heat sink flat line
and season 5's precision caliber and
attention to detail wingman
rampart is the designer behind the two
legendary weapons skins you can unlock
for completing season 6's battle pass
get to level 100 and level 110 and
you'll unlock new skins for the g7
both shoot out flames when you get a
kill one is a white g7 that fires blue
flames
and the other is a black g7 that fires
orange flames you're not completely
naked when you drop in apex legends
anymore
all players will now drop with what's
essentially a level 0 evo shield
deal damage and will upgrade to the
standard level 1 evo shield but it won't
fill until you pop a shield cell
from there it will upgrade as normal
dealing damage isn't the only way to
upgrade your evoshield anymore
whether it's the one you start with or
when you loot you can now craft stronger
evo shields with season 6
you'll find materials in loot bins as
well as large caches of materials
scattered throughout world's edge like
treasure packs materials don't take up
inventory space and enemies can't loot
them off you
take these materials to brand new
replicator stations and you'll be able
to turn them in for weapons
ammo hop-ups or evil shield levels you
won't always be able to craft the same
items though while some items will
remain permanent fixtures at replicators
for the season some will only be in the
stations for a week
others may only be in a replicator for a
day before rotating out
one of the best things about materials
is that you don't lose them upon death
so if your teammates
manage to revive you and you have a lot
of materials on you you can find a
replicator and secure some decent loot
instead of hoping to find some untouched
bins
there are plenty of new ways to get
around world's edge too new pathways
have been carved into the mountains like
a tunnel that takes you directly from
the dome to the tree
there are also a lot of new geysers to
ride additionally there are new
locations to visit too
a giant rocket launch pad has been built
between the dome and sorting factory and
drill site has been transformed into a
brand new location
the small unnamed village in the valley
between raj voyage and the vault tunnel
that leads the train yard has been
transformed into a major landmark too
the train is gone and in its place you
can now discover abandoned train cars
and the previously empty tunnels
scattered throughout the map these train
cars hide loot and open up world's edge
tunnel system as a worthwhile avenue for
exploring
and moving around the map there's also a
new addition that may prove the saving
grace or doom for certain squads
blast doors now dot world's edge
activate them and they'll close off
entire lanes
providing you with a means of cutting
off a squad on your heels if you're
caught behind a blast door you'll need
to go around or hope you have a
pathfinder or octane and your squad to
go over
depending on how the zone is closing you
could definitely use a blast door to
funnel most squads in a certain
direction
quest mode returns in season 6 but it
drops the short pve hunt missions
instead you just get more story but it's
not simple text logs this time around
with season 6 quest transitions into a
full-on apex legends comic
created by darkhorse season 6's battle
pass will offer over 100 items including
brand new hollow spray rewards we've
already seen one of them
lobo left one as her calling card in one
of the world's edge volts
ahead of her release in season five
season six has plenty of cool looking
epic and legendary skins as well
including a hooded outfit for bloodhound
and a sweet black and green look for
octane
[Music]
and that's everything we know about apex
legend season 6. for now anyway
be sure to check back in on gamespot
we're putting together a rampart legend
guide
will continue to cover apex legends
throughout season 6 boosted
[Music]
you